vous savez en amusant david bowie que
j'invitais une star une idole
bonjour dérivés merci de votre
habitation je ne savais pas que ça
provoquerait un tel remue ménage et une
telle affluence de photographes on n'a
jamais vu ça je crois sur le plateau it
/ live c'est votre vie tous les jours et
venez july 10 non non non il est modeste
l'espoir et kyle williams suis sûr qu'à
tokyo et je sais qu'à tokyo à londres et
dans l'avancement à bangkok y en a
parfaitement avant l'avènement de
photographes vouloir reculer car il va
falloir que nous parler un petit peu
avec david bowie ça va être facile pour
les problèmes de son exil prenne trop
ici jimmy carter j'ai l'impression dans
ce marché david bowie merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté notre invitation je les
dis vous êtes avare d'interviews fait de
télévision avec quoi donc l'actuel
commuée en dix titres pays et je
voudrais savoir ce que vous pensez de
tout ce qui se passe autour de vous à
diouf il when you see this photograph
news magazine vous avez 30 ans est aux
affaires
le rayon et vous avez déjà une carrière
de dix à douze ans passés
you are in this is this show business
you show business il est allé vagniez et
l'avenue quelle est votre impression de
pression be stars movistar a single man
un voyageur
sa vie est faite de voyages tout le
temps et c'est ça depuis déjà une
dizaine d'années alors ce que les
français ne savent peut-être pas en tout
cas vos fans en tout cas je vais leur
rappeler c'est que david bowie vous avez
été en france il ya déjà 1 10 ou 11 ans
et vous avez fait vos débuts en france
au golf-drouot viennent de sa demie et l
empire un des groupes rock de l'époque
qu'est ce que vous en aviez du club de
fos faster graphics as you drive de
briançon à la première séance photo il
avait fait dans la voix
côté m quelle était la musique que vous
aimiez que vous aimez la musique lors de
la fiac pas exactement la sienne mais
elle rappelle un peu ce qu'on appelle la
punk maintenant musique dont il est un
petit prêt qu un peu un précurseur il
avait déjà fait cette musique il ya dix
ans vous avez changé un petit peu de vie
depuis quelques années puisque vous êtes
également un acteur du challenge en
juillet the go mcafee
yes le film c'était j'ai le titre là
vous allez me le rappeler en anglais les
l'homme qui venait d'ailleurs the man
who fait il voudrait devenir réalisateur
et ça lui a donné l'occasion de faire un
petit peu ses classes il toise un film
de science fiction film de science
fiction la science fiction mais c'était
pas complètement in space le personnage
qu'il avait pu venir de
de l'espace c'est ça bon je voudrais
maintenant savoir pourquoi cette
transformation
j'ai eu beaucoup de mal à vous
reconnaître parce que plus de maquillage
plus ce regard étrange qui avait fait de
vous un personnage c'est fascinant pour
les photographes et pour le public de
des jeunes du monde entier
tout change physique oui les mecs nus
cartes à chaque fois il changeait donc
deux caractères forts et depuis donc
pour ces deux derniers albums ce dernier
s'il a changé de caractère il a donc
changé physiquement il résister tout
sauf des soirées ça agace trop de
frayeurs exactement lui-même pour cela
que le cinéma vous aimez cinéma movie
star du grand écran
cinq films avec cinq médailles en scène
différente
après cette expérience il voudrait faire
sa propre expérience de réalisateur et
de metteur en scène quel est le cinéma
que vous aimez et quels sont les
metteurs en scène européens ou français
la sortie directe doit aux limites
les films un peu intimidant friis langue
mais in thémis film il y avait un peu
intime
l'actrice faux et vous n'aimez pas les
films les grandes superproduction à
caractère musical ait commis entre la
chronique et ça exactement ce qu'a fait
la queue bourget par l'aménageur ils
préfèrent des films beaucoup plus petit
fait un peu par des artisans
merci beaucoup françois voilà parler de
françois truffaut
notre ami david bowie et c'est un
personnage curieux qui aime à la fois le
cinéma de truffaut sud et fassbinder et
le vieux cinéma allemand expressionniste
dont intimiste de frise la remercie
infiniment de votre visite